u.s consumer prices rose 6.2 percent
last month compared to october 2020 a
30-year high it's made markets nervous
that the fed could tighten monetary
policy sooner than expected
much of the surge had was seen in energy
prices but food prices also rose sharply
meanwhile in japan producer price
inflation has hit its highest level in
more than 40 years with wholesale prices
surging as a result of high commodity
and fuel prices the data means the
world's four largest economies the
united states china japan and germany
have all reported record inflation
numbers for october
let's talk more about this with chelsea
delaney our correspondent in frankfurt
chelsea
economists politicians leaders of
central banks they've all been saying oh
don't worry
this inflation is going to be temporary
now this fresh data is that changing
their view
yeah i think it is to some degree and i
think it's getting harder and harder to
make the case that this is just a
temporary fluke and we're even seeing
policy makers like those at the federal
reserve start to back away from using
that wording temporary transitory uh
they're less confident that it's going
to be like that because really when we
started to see inflation take off
earlier this year it was thought to be
something
caused by things like
like commodity shortages or energy
shortages but now what we're starting to
see is it really broaden out so food
prices are surging
prices for furniture for clothing it's
starting to be a very broad-based
increase in inflation
and that's something that could really
spill over onto consumers and businesses
because their paychecks are going to be
worth less and they might stop spending
as much so it is becoming a better a
bigger threat to the to the broader
economy
a broad-based phenomenon okay so how
much more likely is it that this data
that what we see is going on right now
will prompt the fed
to trigger much more aggressive monetary
policies
yeah it's a good question i think right
now investors aren't really expecting
this to make the fed come out very very
aggressive start raising interest rates
immediately but they do expect that
maybe next year so the fed is in a bit
of a difficult position because
inflation is definitely surging but at
the same time the labor market hasn't
fully recovered from the pandemic there
are still millions of jobs
shorter than they were at the beginning
of the pandemic so there's still a lot
of work to do on the labor recovery
right now investors generally expect the
fed to start raising interest rates
around the middle of next year so
that is something that could eat into
the stock market gains we've seen
chelsea delaney in frankfurt thank you